why would anyone be listening in Germany
very glad to have this next guest on not
what you're used to on ladder with
Crowder shifting gears from politics a
little bit but a guy who I've read for a
while you can pick up his book actually
starting strength it's probably the
single book that anyone is looking to
get strong and unhealthy should read
starting strength calm coach mark Ripert
oh thank you for being on the show sir
what's that sigh for right off the bat
you don't sound happy to be here
I mean we're fellow travelers right
right on strength you're in the Planet
Fitness I've got a barbell Jim you
planet I know I tell you what I didn't
know it was as bad as it was until I
went they don't have a squat rack that's
just part of the main their sales are
and they're very effective sales
organization and in fact I'll tell you a
story if you're you're up for it if we
want to segue back into your trolling
situation you had with him earlier in
the week welcome time ago when I first
opened my gym 84 friend of mine was
running a promotion a sales promotion
that really precedes the the model that
that Planet Fitness uses right now
they're primarily designed to appeal to
people that are not going to use the
membership right that you're holding
their sales model is sell cheap
memberships to people who will not use a
gym membership but that are cheap enough
that people will not stop the draft off
that's the whole model right and we had
a deal with drawing kind of a lead box
based promotion back a long time ago
that said that you want a free
membership to the Wichita Falls Athletic
Club as a concert
Latian prize that somebody's gonna win a
vacation in Hawaii all you have to do to
claim this free membership to the gym is
to come in and pay the maintenance fees
of $96 French was stuff like fifty three
dollars here now 46 or I can't do the
math but there was 96 dollars for two
years worth you gotta - you remember
here for 96 bucks now people that are
regular gym members don't put their name
in lead boxes anyway so the thing
generated quite a bit of cash up front
and he generated a grand total of about
five people that use that membership for
the next few years well kind of the
hundreds of people signed up for this
thing I'll tell you what though I've
been a member of some of those gyms that
aren't quite Planet Fitness but they
have you know a few squat racks and
their goal is to get as many to sign up
with cheap rates and sometimes you do
join up and you know how to use it
properly and you're the only person in
the gym and it's great there was a gym
actually in Texas that I went to which
actually funnily that you talked about
it and that's why I wanted to bring you
on - a lot of people don't realize this
I mean you're more libertarian I'm
libertarian conservative what bothers me
about the fitness industry is the
scamming I mean for example I have my
wife right now and she cannot find a
trainer who will get her doing the right
things and won't listen to me I hear you
muttering angrily this is this industry
is is such that you walk in to a fitness
industry gym and the kids got a shirt on
that says trainer right right how do you
know that is a layperson know the
difference between him and me anyway you
go by your sweet pecs I do not any way
to tell oh I don't do that again
there's not any way for a layperson to
tell and it's a it's a problem it really
is yeah well and that being said my
first gym ever I've talked about this on
air was energy cardio was the only gym
around Montreal where I was on the south
shore that would allow my parents to
sign off I was 13 I was a fat little kid
and it was the only gym that would allow
my
to sign off on me going without them
being present and they didn't have a
squat rack they had all the other
freeways so their dumbbells did go up to
their credit 210 pounds so I was allowed
to do deadlifts and I did those I wasn't
really able to squat for the first few
years which I was you're a big proponent
of that but I remember that it wasn't
the best gym but it was better than
nothing in our school and Canadian
schools there were there were no
athletic programs we didn't have any
serious free weights so wasn't like
American kids have it and that started
me on my journey and then the the really
serious games came actually it wasn't
your program but very similar bill stars
five times five and you know it changed
changed my life I think a lot of people
out there don't realize we talked about
this with Brett McKay the strenuous life
challenging yourself every day to better
yourself as a man as a woman as a person
it's very important in that's where you
talk about progressive overloading with
training is a great example of that if
you do it you'll get better and you'll
you'll become stronger I think it's very
important to for any human being to know
where the limits are yes
because if you don't know where the
limits are then you have no idea what
you can in fact do and the only way to
fight to know where your limits are is
to exceed them occasional right and it
takes a lot of effort takes a lot of
much people are willing to do it now and
it's a lot easier like you talked about
the fitness industry you know my wife
has never done a squat and the fact is
I'll tell you this this is the true
story just happened yesterday she went
in with a personal trainer I handed him
I handed them your book said I want are
doing this I'm paying for a glorified
babysitter she won't listen to me or to
any of it you can't coach your wife no
okay well it's a pretty simple thing you
cannot well I will tell you this so that
happened and they had are doing
everything except squatting we have to
go to the break so finish this on the
let you take the range where we come
back but
she's tall she's six foot and she's slim
and she's gorgeous she modeled for a
long time that's nature and the first
thing the trainer asked he said listen
I'll give you a discount if you let me
put you on my blog as an after picture
taking credit for God's work we'll be
right back with coach mark Ripert Oh a
ladder with Crocker stay tuned very
excited back with the one and only coach
Mark report oh I said that told you that
story before the break and isn't that
the truth and people come in and say hey
can you make me look like mrs. Crowder
and it's just the way she was born you
can't I think you have stumbled on to
one of the problems with the strength
conditioning business in in general the
strengthen conditioning business
nowadays is largely it's this is the
deceptive mess yeah extremely extremely
talented athletes are extremely talented
athletes because they were born that way
right and in terms of their athletic
talent all of the skipping around in the
floor and balance drills and high level
d1 college looking activities that are
designed to hone the abilities of very
very talented athletes are a complete
absolute waste of time extremely
talented athletes aren't made any better
by these types of just look around at
the one college programs they're done
made any better by these these exercises
and activities that are designed to
display talent right there this blank
talent that's already there they're
developing anything sure and you know
the the model is that strength of is in
coaches strength efficient coaches by
saying that right strength and
conditioning coaches are primarily
primarily designed they've primarily
designed their activity and time in the
gym around activities that are designed
to
display the talent of the athlete which
in the model of the industry is designed
to display the town of the coach it
doesn't it just right now like well like
CrossFit there's a lot of those things
now where it started I know you worked
with it but I have guys coming going
look I can do a single leg overhead
barbell squat on top of a kettlebell I
say wow well it's good it's good that
you can do that you're talented enough
to do that that's wonderful right but
now the question becomes as the strength
and conditioning coach what do I do to
make you better
right have you do the other leg you just
displayed to me a fantastic talent for
balance you know
d1 programs primarily recruit on the
basis of a suite of activities that are
centered around measuring vertical jump
because these indicate the the set an
explosive athletic genetics they're
looking for you take a guy over the 36
inch vertical he's gonna make any coach
look pretty good because he's a good
athlete
Brendan whether the coach does anything
for him or not is largely irrelevant
because he already looks good because
that's why you recruited well let me ask
you this before we get off into you have
to understand a lot of people listening
aren't that far along the trail so well
let me ask you this what would be your
advice to someone who's not
yeah yes yes even if you are Li the one
thing that you can always control is to
get stronger
anybody can get stronger unless you are
a strength specialist
anybody can get stronger and for any one
old person that doesn't do that legs
young 18 year old kid looking to go to
college and play sports the most
important thing they can do is the thing
that they can make the most difference
doing and that is just a program right
and you know what I will say this
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu grappling which is I
guess sort of my sport I mean I'm not if
you're not in a pro sport you're not in
college you'd have to pick something
my dad's more accomplished in the
from a lot of them just don't get strong
I'm gonna work on technique and that
obviously is important and we've talked
about this off air there is a point of
diminishing returns and as someone whose
strength during my whole life I know
where that is where I go okay now it's
time to maintain this because ten more
pounds on this barbell at the end of the
year is not going to be time best served
compared to spending time on my sport
but getting to that baseline is so
important people have an extremely
skewed perspective about where that
baseline is sure and a guy like you
you're 27 6 foot 200 5 no no I'm 6 to
226 to 220 Stephen you ought to be
squatting you know for 75% fire and the
fact that you're not indicates to me
that you're not at baseline you see what
I mean yeah and that's impressive but
you don't have the appreciation yeah but
I will say this mark and I do I love
your book and I recommend it actually to
my producer here to everyone who's
starting strength you give me crap for
the unilateral work but I did earlier
but you have to understand I did have to
severely herniated discs I lost all
actual motor function in my legs they
were pricking me with pins so if there
was a time where I had to focus on
maximal loading that I could with
minimal spinal compression and that was
where I found a system that worked for
me to maintain strength and actually
increase flexibility mobility to the
point where I felt like I could get back
to barbells now I will say this I'm
right now I am yeah oh yeah I don't
deadlift I won't tell if right now she
squats and benches and overhead press I
mean you know I have a torn rotator I
told you that before I tore my rotator I
did 23 pull-ups okay I don't wanna get
this competition cuz here's a fact I
traded my 54 year old father and he
would be the least efficient at lifting
barbells and you would choke everyone in
your gym out
and that's the skill set that's most
important to me is combat with with
extremely high skill level right very
masculine that doubles his squat all of
a sudden got better without improving
skills I agree but let me say this I
agree completely I agree completely but
if you look at like heavyweight
champions right now like Boucher share
people like that there is a point and I
don't know that you've ever tried to
gain strength while doing grappling or
wrestling six seven sessions a week it
is very very difficult to do it's very
catabolic it's very hard if I do
grappling even when I tone down the the
strength train to three times a week it
is very hard for me to get above 205 so
is that it might be to your advantage to
maybe get stronger which takes twice a
week in that shirt they perk those two
strength training sessions in so that
your strength would progress and that
total benefit obtained by doing that
might very well make up for the loss of
time on the man oh and that's what I'm
doing right now because I can't spend
time on the mat if I ought to give an
idea that's a great example with your
program it is it's obviously you know
there's certainly so much recovery you
have so when I was doing your program
and lifting pretty heavy right now and
just did some drilling and MIT work was
incredibly sore it was very difficult to
recover from both activities and that's
why I've put that on hold because of the
injuries but I do I advocate your
program or something similar generally
your program exactly for everyone I know
who's starting lifting we're actually
getting this gentleman here who's we
won't bring him in but my producer Jared
who is a hundred and forty-five pounds
and needs to start lifting heavy but I
do want to get to the sort of the macro
issue here I'm writing a column right
now and you can tell me if you agree or
disagree I believe that we've reached a
point in the Planet Fitness thing it
wasn't about the transgender deal or the
cross-dressing it was about I truly
believe and you talk about this
with with weightlifting and I think in
every aspect of life you have to look at
yourself correct yourself and at the end
of the day you have to look yourself in
the mirror and say did I do everything I
could do to get better have I done
everything I can to prepare for whatever
your job may be if so yes let's get to
work but now if I were raised in modern
politically correct liberal America I
believe I would be fat weak and feel
good about myself
sure because we've gotten to a point I
will say this flat-out liberalism
creates fat weak
young men who feel good about being and
not just I'm not talking about
physically in character and if you look
at people like Roosevelt and Abraham
Lincoln that's I use this term the
strenuous life they talked about every
day pushing yourself a little bit would
you have a lot of people who come in or
young men who just don't have that
sensibility of hey this is going to be
hard and that's what's beautiful in it I
don't know most people that start this
program thinking of terms okay I think
that they they come in understanding
that this is what they need but they
haven't they haven't couched it in terms
of their place on the political spectrum
you and I can be philosophical about
this but and and we did it but because
we've got time to do that but a kid
that's you know working full-time at
Sonic drive-in he's 19 years old he's
underweight he knows he needs to be
bigger he doesn't think about it in
those terms he just knows that
everything he's tried before hasn't
worked and he knows that he's heard that
what we can do could tell him suite
comes in but stepping back from the ER
from the immediate nature of such a
thing I agree with your bigger point I
agree with your point that the pressure
now is is to be accepting of complacency
sure because places he's easier at
complacency is the kind of thing that
enables people to feel good about
themselves when somebody else tells them
that that's really all you need to do it
by the Pushcart flatfish shark why why
quite test your own limits right we're
here to make those limits nice and low
we're here to make you comfortable and
comfort is the most important thing you
can be and satisfied with yourself and
high self esteem and all that others
that you've got it's just kind of a kind
of an odd time in the history of the
human race I think for those of you
listening to rest early mark has the
most disgusted look on his face it's it
really is we've got on the one hand a
society where PSAs on the radio were
telling us one in four people are
struggling with hunger those of you
listening out to restaurant have heard
this PSAs are on the station today
wanted for I'm one of one and four I
mean I'm the first and tried to have two
elevator with you and I'm struggling
with hunger yeah
what's the obesity rate in the United
States right well you guys make up your
mind all right we can't have it both
ways and the the politically expedient
nature of both of these messages the
fact that they can flick with each other
doesn't seem to bother anybody it's just
real it's great yeah it's also funny to
me you know yeah Michelle Obama who
declared it a national crisis right a
bigger threat than global terrorism no
the obesity thing but I always say she
needs to listen to more radio if she did
she'd understand that is struggling sure
honey
well I don't think she's struggling with
hunger and that wasn't what I was
implying but I guess I just said it now
we'll be right back with coach mark
ripto after this break we're will see
how much more inappropriate we
get back in this next hour we went
through the hour now we're still back
with Coach mark reptile before this we
were talking about hunger versus obesity
in this country that's a good point you
know I talked about that though - if
obesity is our biggest epidemic as some
leftists say I know I mean if you had to
pick your problem out of a pile wouldn't
that be the one you would first pick a
problem of overabundance and choice I
can't imagine a better problem to have
yes
manufactured struggling this is as I
said this is an interesting this is an
interesting time in the history of the
human race we've got a giant dichotomy
and I know this is pointer bothers
leftists we have a huge segment of the
world's population that don't get enough
to eat right
and then again here we are in the United
States where you can walk in to a
grocery store you can walk into Walmart
and buy a pre-made pancakes with the
pancakes already made or you mean the
mix okay but my position is that the
dichotomy is not my problem
the dichotomy is the problem of the
third world who refuses to embrace the
idea that private property and free
market capitalism provides for pre-made
pancakes
and I'm using this as a metaphor for the
whole thing but I don't know if you
really want to get me started
no I don't think I do I don't think I
did I don't know I agree with you well I
mean listen they don't have the problem
of obesity you know try getting some
Zambian famine victims head around it
they won't even be able to comprehend
that your problem is you have too much
to eat anorexia nervosa insanity I look
I don't think you have a lot of body
builders oiled and tanned bitching about
their calves so
no probably not the body dysmorphia on
either side so we get back to you talk
about getting stronger let me ask you
this okay
to go back to strength training how do
you handle it I've gotten to a point in
my life where I am just so tired with
the BS and I feel like it's everywhere
and it's no more prevalent than in the
supplement industry and the fitness
industry Planet Fitness as an example
but it's I mean literally I cannot find
one decent personal trainer to to whom I
can take my wife and we are just
literally if you're looking at Planet
Fitness for decent personal trainer you
seem to have some serious misconceptions
about this no not Planet Fitness the
vast majority Planet Fitness is on the
extreme in throughout this continuum
you've got the standard industry model
gyms which are basically sales
organizations and then you've got on the
far other end of the spectrum places
like Wichita Falls have let me flip out
the door here that has the sign on the
door that says Wichita Falls Athletic
Club is a private strength training
facility and membership is by invitation
only we turn people away here that don't
sufficient sufficiently appreciate what
it is we're trying to do okay well let
me real quick because people are going
to attack you the middle is you know
there is the functional training
expression of them of the business
that's come along CrossFit is part of
that there are right in the middle is
really where more trainers ought to be
and they're not right that serve a
larger percentage of population sure now
let me ask you this because people will
say you turn people away so that's why
Planet Fitness exists you just want to
judge fat people now I know that you've
trained you to have some old ladies
between at your gym it's not about where
you are it's about how serious you are
with self-improvement right it's about
whether you came into
Jim for the fact that we have a logical
arithmetic 'old model for making you
stronger start where you are now go up a
little bit every day right or if you
came in for pizza tonight you know if
you came in for pizza night yeah we're
gonna probably draw a conclusion based
on is that judgment well I guess you
know what everyone's that's just
semantics okay but no my 91 year old gal
that trades in here will be in here
tomorrow about noon fact it's capable of
doing an unassisted
bodyweight squat below parallel Wow
confirm and that's been a long process
but we've gotten her to the point where
she hasn't fallen down and in a year she
doesn't use her Walker anymore of it's
been in her closet for about ten months
and the same process that we use for
athletes we use for her right we started
a different place sure and it's funny
you know I see that and people see the
Planet Fitness thing and say no
judgement because we don't want to be
mean I hear that story that you just
tell me and I think how mean are you
other personal trainers to rob this
woman of that experience of the
opportunity yeah put her Walker in the
closet at the age of good for her are
there any pictures online or videos yeah
we've got a little video online I've
just looked up Gus G us mrs. Virginia
Gustafson is on look up Gus W FAC and
they'll be a nice little video comes up
91 years old cheese Alexis goes to show
people listen the same process that you
steven crowder need to be good I am
doing it right now
oh look all right let me ask you and you
said you've never offered to come coach
me okay no no ha a second don't make me
mute your mind
don't make me mute your microphone
because you just asked me if I did
deadlifts on air when you were the one
who specified you said oh you got a torn
rotator
yeah good mornings are good you should
do those you don't need to be dead
lifting or doing powerpoints and you
know what I did three weeks post-op a
deadlift at 3:15 because dad laughs
don't bother a torn rotor
well they do mine well maybe that's not
what you got maybe it's not what I've
got but everyone listening I'm following
his protocol I called him with questions
he said yeah that actually seems good if
you can do it and stop irritating your
back those are good replacements and
then he comes on here and tries to throw
me under the bus so I'll tell you what I
will say well you certainly didn't offer
to come out and train me you're asking
me about the Cherry Festival okay okay
you come out here I will be glad to and
you can train my wife yeah put her up on
starting strength and say look look at
my handiwork oh yeah she's a very she's
a very trees way out of my league okay
there's something else though is gonna
ask you I don't even remember what it
was now that we got off the the beaten
off the beam bet I was gonna say this
okay you talk about strength training if
I'm a sort of parlay that into something
I don't know if you've ever been on the
grappling mats but I would invite you to
go on there once everyone should get
their ass kicked once it's good for your
soul it's good to realize how a marcelo
garcia looking character who you would
see in the gym and see his weak can feel
so strong and absolutely ends your life
at any time they want to just to realize
that strength is important but it does
not make a complete oh you know I'll
tell you what is even more importantly
right youth I don't know I enjoy what's
your Kim you laid all the injuries I've
got you know at one time I was about you
know halfway tough now just old yeah I
tell you what though we've had guys who
came in who were halfway tough we've had
division what we've had pro football
players come in and
just get there just just a life choked
down and there's nothing do about her
thank God I don't have to deal I just
deal with the thing that makes everybody
sport better and that's getting strong
that's getting strong that is absolutely
true and on that we completely agree and
it has to be done with certainly heavy
weights for people who are starting with
measurable loading increase is really I
thought that's the process I thought I
could just go CrossFit and go ape crap
crazy with a barbell and train for
randomness what you're blowing my mind
in random now that doesn't seem to work
in other words you can't learn to play
the piano by a combination of attempting
to play the saxophone the guitar and
digging a hole in the backyard well what
age do you cross over into the
nonsensical okay all right well we have
to we have to get going and maybe well
maybe we'll keep you on for another
online segment for terrestrial we must
say goodbye where can people vest find
you mark my web site I'm there way too
much today so just feel free to contact
me through that website our flips and
DVD are for sale on that website we're
also available on amazon.com our German
translation is available on amazon.com
you're gonna throw the HTTP in there the
German translations in amazon.de if
they're Germany I'm sure Italy routes
them ok why would anyone be listening in
Germany mark rip Otto starix Frank calm
whether you're 91 years old or 19 I
highly recommend it mark thanks for
being with us brother
subscribe by clicking my face or click
this video next to me it's playing right
now in a box how do we do that
that's the magic of the internet is it
still playing I'm still playing I don't
want to look at it still playing isn't
it